remember Gullah Gullah island the 90s
kidz show on Nick jr. featuring a fun
family and a Polliwog named Bing abiy
[Music]
well it's a real place kind of I'm
Natalie Dave and I played Miss Natalie
Galaga on my name is Ron days and I
served as a dad
show me how old you are shame there is
no real place named pehla pehla island
except on TV it is based on the Gullah
Geechee culture which was passed on by
enslaved west africans who were brought
to this country called eg culture was
born out of several African cultures and
languages brought here by enslaved
people everything from cuisines and
traditional practices have been
maintained through generations of
settlement in coastal villages in
Georgia and the Carolinas
I am telugu Qi and proud of it it's
important to me to make sure that Gullah
Geechee culture is preserved because
it's a very important factor of American
cultural heritage when Natalie and Ron
got the opportunity to present their
culture on TV they jumped at the chance
by the time we met the woman who became
an executive producer we had been
traveling around the country doing
stories and songs the Gullah culture
that's what we did in the beginning we
didn't know that it was so significant
there had never been a show like that
before we wanted a show where our
children could see themselves we
actually ended up with a show where
everybody could see themselves in us
before we go would you guys mind seeing
us out and let's play together in the
[Music]